Israel has entered what it calls a new
phase of its war against
Hamas with a military Advan deep into
the heart of
Gaza Israel has launched ground
invasions of Gaza before most recently
in
2009 and 2014 Israel is at War but this
time Israeli forces plan to go further
in a multiphased offensive into gaza's
sprawling cities with the aim of
destroying the military cap abilities of
Hamas a US designated terror
group here's a look at how Israeli
Ground Forces invaded Gaza in 2009 and
2014 and what that reveals about
Israel's current
operation Israeli Ground Force most
far-reaching military incursion into
Gaza came during operation K sled in
2009 in response to a barrage of Hamas
Rockets thousands of Israeli troops
entered Gaza from the north and east
under the cover of artillery
fire the 3-we offensive saw extensive
Street to street fighting as Israeli
Ground Forces pushed towards Gaza City
with the aim of taking control of rocket
launch
sites you have to understand the the way
the Gaza is built yasi cavasa is a
former head of Israel's Military
Intelligence Division between the
populated area and the Israeli
territory there's an open area it's very
difficult to to move towards the
populated area because you totally
exposed as soldiers Advanced towards
gaza's major cities they reported
finding dozens of buildings booby
trapped with explosives intended to
inflict casualties on Israeli troops
that's why we prefer to prepare the
battlefield by a lot of air strikes to
weaken the enemy so that when we enter
their their abilities are going to be
decimated during the offensive the IDF
remained on the outskirts of gaza's main
cities this kept Israel's casualties low
but limited its ability to Target Hamas
infrastructure in builtup areas we
didn't mean to take over Gaza in 2009 we
dealt with the outskirts of some of the
main cities but didn't have any
intention to actually enter the center
of town we didn't put a goal for
ourselves the uprooting of Kamas from
entirely we realized that Hamas is going
to stay in place and that was a mistake
because all these rounds were ended with
an agreement that enabled Hamas to rearm
itself pretty
soon by the time the operation ended
with Israel's implementation of a
unilateral ceasefire 1,300 Palestinians
and 13 Israelis have been killed a un
fact finding Mission found evidence
suggesting both Palestinian armed groups
and Israel committed actions amounting
to war crimes during the
conflict Israel's most recent ground
offensive into Gaza was limited in scope
to destroying aspects of Hamas
infrastructure in The
Enclave in July 2014 Israel launched
operation protective Edge in response to
rockets and mortar fire from Hamas the
Israeli government initially launched an
aerial operation to destroy a vast
network of underground tunnels Hamas had
constructed to store weapons including
Rockets fired by the group into Israel
after Hamas militants used the tal to
launch a raid on a kabut in southern
Israel the government authorized ground
troops to cross into Gaza with the aim
of destroying crossb
tunnels every attempt to enter the Gaza
Strip on the ground it involves first of
all anti-tank missiles mines booby traps
that are located in places where you
want to enter Israeli troops and armor
pushed into
Gaza in an effort to locate the
entrances to the Border
tunnels during the 7we operation the IDF
said it discovered 62 mies of tunnels
the problem with tunnels is that you
don't see them it was not easy for us to
locate them and we had to have a very
strong intelligence effort to find out
where they are we had to develop
technique that would explode them and
make them not
function Israel says its troops
destroyed 32 tunnels 14 of which
infiltrated into Israeli
territory the 2014 conflict ended when
troops withdrew from Gaza under a
ceasefire agreement reached at the end
of August that year the logic at the
time was that we inflict this heavy blow
on on their infrastructure cost them a
lot of uh operatives and deal harshly
use their Rockets launching capabilities
to the point that they will ask for
ceasefire under our conditions sometimes
it took longer and sometimes it took
shorter time before they resumed the
terror operations but they were always
were capable of recovering relatively
fast the fighting had killed 2,000
Palestinians and 72
Israelis United Nations panel found
evidence indicating war crimes may have
been committed by both with Israel and
Palestinian militant groups during the
conflict Israel's previous ground
offensives in Gaza were much more
limited in scope than what its military
is aiming to do now since Hamas took
power in Gaza Israel hasn't tried to
eliminate the group's military
infrastructure and leadership in The
Enclave for many many years any of the
previous rounds we tried not to end up
with taking over Gaza but seems that
this time we just cannot afford any
other solution we have to take Gaza a
ground Invasion with the aim of going
into gaza's cities to destroy Hamas
presents one of the biggest challenges
the Israeli military has faced in
decades this is a dangerous move for any
army it has to be done slowly and
carefully and will cost a lot of
[Music]
lives